6 25 on your wednesday morning was
driving to crazy speeders
again viewer cheryl writes hey they
should rename the 215 all the way from
gibson down in henderson to cheyenne in
the northwest valley the las vegas motor
speedway practice track she says the
left lane at all hours a day is a
roaring thrill ride for some drivers she
says hey i set my cruise control to 65
and if i'm in the far left lane which i
avoid like crazy she says she says i'm
run up on obscene gestures and they're
gone around me so fast i can't even get
a glimpse of the license plate and she
adds what happened to police on the
overpasses and motorcycle officers
chasing them down please patrol and stop
these idiots cheryl i will pass your
note along but i can tell you that the
highway patrol folks from the nevada
state police they've talked in the past
about the priority of getting impaired
drivers off the road and they do go
after speeders but i'm guessing they're
never going to run out of volunteers for
the social media post highlighting the
folks who endanger their own lives and
those of everyone around them when
they're busted at speeds over a hundred
miles an hour and i get your point about
renaming the road but i'm pretty sure
it's going to remain the bruce woodbury
beltway in honor of the man who served
many years on the clark county
commission uh instrumental in getting
that project off the ground buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone if you want to comment or if
there's something else driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com